new york a tranché alors que le pays a
franchi ce mercredi la barre des 250
mille décès le maire de la ville qui ne
dort jamais a annoncé la fermeture des
écoles publiques à compter de ce jeudi
new york seule métropole américaine à
avoir ouvert ses établissements
scolaires à la rentrée capitule face à
la hausse des cas de copie de 19 à ce
jour sur notre moyenne mobile de 7 jours
de positivité au coronavirus la ville de
new york a atteint exactement 3 % et par
conséquent nous devons fermer nos écoles
dans les jours à venir
personne n'est heureux de cette décision
en fait nous en sommes tous très tristes
car beaucoup de travail a été fait pour
garder les écoles ouvertes mais nous
avons fixé une norme très clair et nous
devons nous y tenir
et je tiens à souligner aux parents aux
éducateurs aux personnels aux enfants
que nous avons l'intention de revenir et
de revenir aussi vite que possible une
décision qui suscite l'incompréhension
des habitants
et pour cause la ville la plus
endeuillée aux états unis lors de la
première vague semble plutôt bien
résisté à présent malgré les 3 % de
positivité au qu'ovide 19 l'état de new
york ainsi que la métropole
figurent parmi les moins touchées du
pays les parents d'élèves déplorent
cette décision de fermer les écoles
c'est vraiment malheureux que ses
enfants soient privés d'éducation mais
on peut aller dîner dans un restaurant
ça n'a aucun sens pour moi ça n'a
absolument aucun sens cela provoque
beaucoup de stress un stress inutile
nous n'avons pas besoin de fermer les
seuils le nombre de seuils est encore
bas nous sommes toujours ok et ce n'est
tout simplement pas bon pour les parents
c'est beaucoup de pression pour nous une
fermeture annoncée comme temporaire mais
dont la durée est encore inconnue de
nouvelles mesures liées à la réouverture
des écoles sont attendus cette semaine
pour l'heure les autorités américaines
craignent une nouvelle flambée de
l'épidémie avec les célébration de
thanksgiving le 26 novembre